Does that break up any questions or concerns for anybody?
I do have a question about this Dr. Conner.
I have several people in my life that are telling me, oh, we've got to go get surgery and
not quite certain how to handle them.
One of them specifically is in her 10th round of chemotherapy.
And I just need some words of wisdom as what to say to them.
I mean, I wrote down what you just said about putting in the hands of our Heavenly Father.
And I totally believe that.
But sometimes it gets overwhelming.
They think they're being nice good to me, but it gets to the point where I'm avoiding
people now.
Well, I'd suggest you go and you read the book of Galatians because honestly, that has helped
me a lot to deal with people that disagree with me.
I just started it this morning.
So the truth is, from a psychological standpoint, people want you to do what they're doing because
it justifies what they're doing.
And if you're doing what they're, even if they're running off of a cliff and jumping off
of a cliff, as long as there's more people doing it, then they feel good about it.
So and I'm not saying that what that person is doing is wrong for her or him, but when
when someone is judging you, you can feel it, can't you?
Oh, yes.
And so make sure that you're not judging other people.
Don't judge them that they're doing the wrong thing because you're going to be judged the
same way.
Okay.
So just go, hey, whatever is right for you that you should do that.
But don't judge me on what I'm doing.
I really respect that or we're going to have to distance ourselves from each other a little
bit during this process.
There isn't anything wrong with doing that.
And if that person is really a real friend, they'll, you know, apologize and they'll respect
your decision.
They're, if they're so insecure about their decision-making process, they're going to
be more apt to pressure you to do what they're doing because that will give them more security.
So it's really coming from that person's insecurity, but it still doesn't feel good.
So I understand that.
So you're, you're just going to, you might have to have a talk with that person if they're
close.
If they're a family member that you, that they're not, that they're always going to be in
your life.
If they're not a family member, that's going to be not in your life and you could, you know,
move them, move that relationship a little, make a little distance in that relationship.
It might be the best thing to do.
Okay.
Thank you.
The biggest thing is you want to respect everybody's decision because it's their decision.
And when you, when we stop judging other people, then we're not judged with that same judgment.
But even when we stop judging other people, people could be judging us.
And those are people that maybe we either have a talk with and say, you know, you're judging
me on the decision-making.
You need to respect my decision or we need to not talk so much.
And if they're truly a friend and they're truly mature, then they should be able to handle
that.
If, if not, then, then maybe, maybe it was time to say goodbye for a while.
So that, that would be by a period.
So thank you.